hi guys hi I'm just McDonald I'm sorry T
and we're here for another week of house
Mars the weekly live show on games
when we play our games and some loud
loud don't know if it's this a lot of
you guys gonna turn it down a bit for us
um we're here to play obscure again and
it was pretty fun last time you guys
seemed to like it and we get to play
game together which we don't really get
to do very often at all so right now I
am the girl Serena's the guy why is this
music still so now your shadow looks and
we look at everything yeah and we left
the engine one CD ah sorry I did it bad
you're on a bench that's it intentional
yeah test the physics of the benches all
right
what's with the music it's really
putting me up how can we speed up the
process this acid in that other room
really yes the one with all the monsters
in it oh [ __ ] let's get back hole digger
come up we don't have anything cracking
do you have anything why can't I pick up
the acid maybe miss smash the windows oh
my god yes okay yep thirty seconds
that's a long time okay
do you remember where the room was
nobody killed yes oh my god that's
cheating
was it this way
go you can do it
I'm glad that even when you do it it's
my annoying [ __ ] the cup is disappearing
oh yeah yo I kidding yo yo I get it he's
got a dealer yeah this is ridiculous
yeah okay he's actually Jessie for
making that that's just another baking
bad as well which would have been a way
better show okay now get it this control
seems really of every time you're like
not shiny I run away
Oh
yeah you killed one you killed one but
John okay let me down let me down you're
strong like really bad stitches for
being super unfit go sukashi no point
120 experimental himself way too gonz
yes we should probably be using them huh
let's kill that as soon as we can hey
buddy
nope hey buddy you're not gonna kill
right because I said that you were good
guy no you want to kill
so I walked all the way up to you like
an idiot oh this is so unexpected maybe
just a middle BA get ready boys okay now
I don't know what to do now I'm just
confused because that was what I had
Stan would do that faster
davus I made the best sound it could
have made it works I know it's almost
like that was the code go right now and
see the janitor he'll let you out I'll
tell him you're coming and don't let me
see you back until tomorrow morning but
the creatures I'll take care of
everything the best thing you can do for
now is to get out of
what's with this angle this camera angle
I can stand my god okay stop having this
reaction to try and help everybody
Harrison
mr. garrison Palestinian looks like it's
getting crazy in the infirmary we better
hurry up and help tape player
fast-forward this parts worthless stuff
guy there it's it's Friedman its
Friedman he's locking the door behind
him the bastard who's that guy what's he
doing I just don't get it
hey Kenny he's alive we have to go find
him I love the powerful flashlight
dammit alright you're tough Ashley Wow
I'm ready to rock ok dude let's go
upstairs and rock yeah that
I should get the Saudi out actually
tactic just keep shooting at it is wind
do not opening up the door oh wow okay
all right let's see we haven't to move
the best one at top left because it's
broken and that takes you to talk right
yep yeah yeah that's it right on the
left and then boom
oh my god that's awesome that's actually
really useful and the choir is son
enough again that's only a good thing
what do you mean another one Herbert
Herbert the maniac who kidnapped Kenny
it's Leonard who's Leonard he wants to
get out oh my god she's lost it she's
lost her mind she's dead [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know I almost missed you guys cool
oh my god
Oh real-time I think wheels I'm yeah
sorry dumb [ __ ]
what what's bizarre just the same in
these old photos as he doesn't have what
may be the finished thing no one's
noticed that the principle is immortal
I'm shining that torch on you so hard
you protect me in my g-string jerking
the film is coming with this genetic oh
look at him he's aged oh [ __ ] Kenny
hahaha
we don't even think just [ __ ] shoot
there we go
that's because he's dead Oh something
right
ah that my friends is us having a
realization moment and just one it in
just randomly kilvo handy it can't be
you killed see is dead and now we're
stuck oh yeah stuck being these people
damn that got rough oh you like guns
never used to be a gun person pretty
keen on it uh lended is not doing so
good
wait is it out of the cage now the music
would suggest yes
oh man
and in the bad
I didn't say life time uh obscure again
a game we keep playing because when the
few games that we can play together but
um let us know what you thought and what
you would like to see us play in the
comments on our H right is your life
hashtag that's HOH no whatever you what
I just said um and yeah we'll we'll be
back next week as we tend to be cool
thanks everyone we'll see you next week